Smell has been called our most underappreciated sense. When people think about it, if they think about it at all, many consider it an evolutionary relic, something that is important for animals but not for us humans. We tend to think we aren't even that good at detecting smells, certainly not as good as our dogs, for instance. About 10 years ago, a national poll found that more than half of young people said they'd be willing to give up their sense of smell before they'd give up their laptop or cell phone. But in recent years, scientists have begun to learn more about this overlooks. sense and how to gain a new understanding of how sophisticated human sense of smell really is,
嗅觉被称为我们最被低估的感官。当人们想到它时，如果他们真的会去想的话，许多人会认为它是一种进化的遗迹，对动物很重要，但对我们人类来说却并非如此。我们往往认为自己甚至不擅长探测气味，当然不如我们的狗，例如。大约10年前，一项全国性民意调查发现，超过一半的年轻人表示，他们宁愿放弃嗅觉，也不愿放弃笔记本电脑或手机。但近年来，科学家们开始更多地了解这种被忽视的感官，并开始重新理解人类的嗅觉究竟有多复杂，
and how it is intertwined with our mental and physical health. Now the COVID-19 pandemic is giving this research new urgency, because one common side effect of the virus, even among people with otherwise mild cases, is the loss of smell or changes in the sense of smell. Some people recover their sense quickly, but for others, the changes seem to be long-lasting or perhaps even permanent. Why is this happening? And, and And what are the consequences for those who are affected? More broadly, how important is our sense of smell? What are the connections between smell and our emotions?
以及它如何与我们的身心健康交织在一起。现在，COVID-19大流行赋予了这项研究新的紧迫性，因为该病毒的一个常见副作用，即使是在病情较轻的人群中，也是嗅觉丧失或嗅觉改变。有些人很快恢复了嗅觉，但对另一些人来说，这种变化似乎是长期的，甚至可能是永久性的。为什么会发生这种情况？对于那些受影响的人来说，后果又是什么？更广泛地说，我们的嗅觉有多重要？嗅觉与我们的情绪之间有什么联系？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Pamela Dalton, an experimental psychologist at the Monel Chemical Senses Center in Philadelphia, an independent nonprofit research institute dedicated to studying the senses of taste and smell. Dr. Dalton's research focuses on how our emotions and cognitive processes affect the way that we experience smell and how smell affects our emotions and our memories. She's been called a smell ebriety, especially because of her work to identify the worst smell in the world,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是费城莫内尔化学感官中心的实验心理学家帕梅拉·道尔顿博士，这是一个致力于研究味觉和嗅觉的独立非营利研究机构。道尔顿博士的研究重点是我们的情绪和认知过程如何影响我们体验气味的方式，以及气味如何影响我们的情绪和记忆。她被称为“嗅觉专家”，尤其是因为她致力于识别世界上最难闻的气味，
which we will talk about. How could we not? She's currently leading a research team that's working on a rapid smell-based test called Sentinel to identify cases of COVID-19. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Dalton. That's my pleasure, Kim. Because COVID-19 is top of mind for most of us these days, can you tell our listeners, do researchers know why COVID interferes with the sense of smell
我们将谈论这一点。我们怎么能不谈呢？她目前正在领导一个研究团队，致力于开发一种名为“哨兵”的快速嗅觉测试，以识别COVID-19病例。感谢您今天加入我们，道尔顿博士。这是我的荣幸，金。由于COVID-19是这些天我们大多数人最关心的问题，你能告诉我们的听众，研究人员是否知道为什么COVID会干扰嗅觉
and is loss of smell a common side effect of other viruses? First of all, a loss of smell following a virus has been known before, but it has never been as common or as prevalent as it is with the COVID-19 virus. And so we are experiencing a tremendous surge in people, the prevalence of people who are losing their sense of smell, even for a brief period of time. And what it's doing is making them aware
以及嗅觉丧失是其他病毒的常见副作用吗？首先，病毒引起的嗅觉丧失以前就为人所知，但它从未像COVID-19病毒那样普遍。因此，我们正在经历嗅觉丧失人数的巨大激增，即使只是短暂的。它所做的是让他们意识到
of just how important this sensory system is. I've read reports that COVID can cause both an osmia, the loss of smell, or parosmia changes in smell. Can you talk a little bit about the differences between the two and describe what you and other researchers have found? Yes. Well, certainly it seems that anosmia, which is the complete loss of ability to smell,
这个感觉系统有多重要。我读过报道称，COVID既会导致嗅觉缺失（即嗅觉丧失），也会导致嗅觉倒错（即嗅觉改变）。你能谈谈这两者之间的区别，并描述一下你和其他研究人员发现了什么吗？是的。嗯，当然，嗅觉缺失，也就是完全丧失嗅觉能力，似乎是
is the most dramatic manifestation of a virus, including COVID. It seems like it's turning a light switch off. From one minute you're tasting and smelling, and the next minute that olfactory sense is completely gone. And, of course, that affects not only your ability to smell, but your appreciation of flavor. So if you're drinking or eating something, it's going to taste or have the flavor of something completely different once smell is gone. At that point, however, it turns out that people are not always aware of changes in their sense of smell unless it is completely gone.
病毒（包括COVID）最显著的表现。这看起来就像关掉电灯开关一样。前一分钟你还在品尝和闻气味，下一分钟嗅觉就完全消失了。当然，这不仅影响你的嗅觉能力，还影响你对风味的鉴赏。所以如果你在喝或吃东西，一旦嗅觉消失，它的味道或风味就会变得完全不同。然而，事实证明，除非嗅觉完全丧失，否则人们并不总是意识到嗅觉的变化。
And so studies that have actually measured people's ability to smell objectively as opposed to ask for self-report have found that. that there are many more people who have an alteration. So for example, there is a condition called hyposmia, which is a decrease in your sensitivity, which most people may not be aware of unless they were tested, but it turns out that a really high percentage of people that contract COVID do have either anosmia or hyposmia when tested.
因此，那些客观测量人们嗅觉能力而不是依赖自我报告的研究发现，有更多的人出现了嗅觉改变。例如，有一种情况叫嗅觉减退，即你的敏感度下降，大多数人可能在未接受测试前并未意识到这一点，但事实证明，在接受测试时，很大比例感染COVID的人确实患有嗅觉缺失或嗅觉减退。
Parasmia, on the other hand, is a different condition. It's the ability to smell, but it's the distortion of what things smell like. So your favorite cup of coffee suddenly smells like gasoline or your chocolate energy bar smells a lot like your dog's poop, which is really very disturbing. However, we think this is actually what happens potentially in the process of recovery of smell when you have lost your sense of smell and the odor system. the olfactory system is regenerating. And there's still a lot to be learned about this condition.
另一方面，嗅觉倒错是另一种情况。它是有嗅觉能力的，但气味发生了扭曲。所以你最喜欢的咖啡突然闻起来像汽油，或者你的巧克力能量棒闻起来很像你家狗的粪便，这真的很令人不安。然而，我们认为这实际上可能是你在失去嗅觉后，嗅觉系统在恢复过程中发生的情况。关于这种情况，还有很多需要了解的地方。
It's been very prevalent in COVID, unlike prior viral disorders. And so we're really, unfortunately, having a great opportunity to study it and perhaps understand it in a way we never had the opportunity to do so before. Now, I mentioned in my introduction that smell is an underappreciated sense and that people don't realize how important it is until they lose it. How does the loss of smell or changes in their sense of smell affect people? What are the mental, physical, and emotional results of losing your sense of smell? It's really interesting because people are not aware until they lose it about how much it informs their ability to know where they are in time and space, their environment.
它在COVID中非常普遍，这与之前的病毒性疾病不同。因此，不幸的是，我们确实有了一个很好的机会来研究它，并可能以我们以前从未有过的方式来理解它。现在，我在介绍中提到嗅觉是一种被低估的感官，人们在失去它之前并没有意识到它有多重要。嗅觉丧失或嗅觉改变如何影响人们？失去嗅觉会带来哪些心理、生理和情感上的结果？这真的很有趣，因为人们在失去它之前并没有意识到它在多大程度上帮助他们了解自己在时间和空间中的位置，即他们的环境。
It's sort of the backdrop of everywhere we go and everyone we interact with. It's a piece of the fabric of our lives that we just don't appreciate until it's been cut away. So, for example, people talk about feeling disconnected. People talk about feeling disoriented or lost. They hug a loved one and they feel like there's an important piece of the emotional response it's missing, a recognition of who it is that they didn't even realize was encoded as part of their representation of that person until it was missing. On the Manel Center website, there's a section about how parents can talk to children about
它就像是我们所到之处和所接触之人的背景。它是我们生活结构的一部分，直到它被切断，我们才意识到它的重要性。例如，人们谈论感到脱节。人们谈论感到迷失方向或迷茫。他们拥抱亲人时，感觉缺少了情感反应中重要的一部分，一种对对方的认知，而他们甚至没有意识到这种认知是作为他们对那个人印象的一部分被编码的，直到它消失。在莫内尔中心的网站上，有一个关于父母如何与孩子谈论
the loss of smell. I know children are not as susceptible to COVID as adults, but those who do get it, is the loss of smell as common among children as it is in adults? Quite honestly, Kim, we don't know yet. And that's something that we're trying to learn with our sentinel test, because as you mentioned in your introduction, we're developing a very easy-to-use rapid smell test that we think can be suitable for children. I worked on the National Institutes of Health toolbox odor ID test a number of years ago. And the goal there was to be able to test children as young as three years old in order to be able to. to assess their ability to smell. And this was, irregardless of virus, just sort of understanding the natural ability to smell the same way you would test a child's hearing or their vision, because it is an important sensory system.
嗅觉丧失的部分。我知道儿童不像成年人那样容易感染COVID，但对于那些感染的孩子，嗅觉丧失在儿童中是否像在成年人中一样普遍？老实说，金，我们还不知道。这是我们正试图通过我们的“哨兵”测试来了解的事情，因为正如你在介绍中提到的，我们正在开发一种我们认为适合儿童使用的、非常易于使用的快速嗅觉测试。几年前，我参与了美国国立卫生研究院的工具箱气味识别测试。目标是能够测试低至三岁的儿童，以便能够评估他们的嗅觉能力。这与病毒无关，只是为了了解自然的嗅觉能力，就像你会测试孩子的听力或视力一样，因为它是一个重要的感觉系统。
And so we don't really know what the prevalence is among children, but we do know that children may experience their worlds very differently if they lose their sense of smell, and they may not have the language to communicate what that feels like. probably prior to viral disorders and post-viral olfactory dysfunction, the most common way for children to lose their sense of smell
所以我们并不真正知道它在儿童中的普遍程度，但我们确实知道，如果孩子们失去嗅觉，他们对世界的体验可能会非常不同，而且他们可能没有语言来表达那种感觉。可能在病毒性疾病和病毒后嗅觉功能障碍之前，儿童失去嗅觉最常见的方式
would be following a head injury, a sports-related head injury or something like that. And so that was really the only cases where we actually had a sense of prevalence. And there, it turned out that the sense of smell was actually pretty, how quickly it returned or whether you lost it actually was pretty indicative how serious the head injury was. Post-virally, we're really still learning.
是头部受伤，比如运动相关的头部受伤之类的。所以这确实是我们真正了解患病率的唯一案例。在那里，事实证明嗅觉恢复的速度或是否丧失，实际上非常能说明头部受伤的严重程度。至于病毒后，我们确实还在学习中。
I'm intrigued by the idea you mentioned a little while ago of the fact that you can measure how acute people's sense of smell is and if it changes over time. I mean, we're all used to taking eye tests. We take hearing tests. You know, there are things that I think are sort of baselines that everybody agrees. The E is facing left or right. We know how many decibels that sound is it's coming into our right year. But how do you measure the degree of taste that someone is experiencing? In the laboratory in a research setting, you would probably measure what their threshold is for detection, presenting them the same way you would decrease the size of the letters on an eye chart, or you would decrease the decibels, you would decrease the
我对你刚才提到的一个观点很感兴趣，即你可以测量人们的嗅觉有多敏锐，以及它是否会随时间变化。我的意思是，我们都习惯了做视力测试。我们做听力测试。你知道，我认为有一些基准是每个人都同意的。E字朝左还是朝右。我们知道进入我们右耳的声音有多少分贝。但你如何测量某人正在体验的味觉程度呢？在实验室的研究环境中，你可能会测量他们的探测阈值，就像你减小视力表上字母的大小，或者减小分贝一样，你会减小
concentration of a chemical, and you would ask them at what point they could detect. And there are different ways to do that. That takes a lot of time. It's quite involved. It would be done, especially for clinical purposes, if someone came in and said, I lost my sense of smell, and you would want to evaluate that. But in a rapid screening test,
化学物质的浓度，然后询问他们在什么点可以探测到。有不同的方法可以做到这一点。这需要很多时间。它相当复杂。如果有人进来并说“我失去了嗅觉”，而你想评估这一点，这尤其会用于临床目的。但在快速筛查测试中，
there are other ways to get at that information quickly. And then if you find a problem, you can refer someone for that more involved kind of testing. But it basically follows the same sensory changes that you would use. It's a field called psychophysics. that is used in vision and hearing as well. It's just done with odorants instead of letters or sounds.
还有其他方法可以快速获得这些信息。然后，如果你发现有问题，你可以将某人转诊进行更深入的测试。但它基本上遵循你将使用的相同的感官变化。这是一个被称为心理物理学的领域，它也用于视觉和听觉。它只是用气味剂而不是字母或声音来完成。
Most patient's sense of smell does seem to come back eventually, I understand, but for those who have long-lasting effects, is there hope or there treatments that you can use to help people regain their sense of smell? And can you train yourself to smell again? There is some hope. It turns out that at least with COVID, most people do recover their sense of smell. Sometimes even in a week or two following the initial other symptoms
据我了解，大多数患者的嗅觉最终似乎会恢复，但对于那些有长期影响的人，是否有希望或治疗方法可以帮助人们恢复嗅觉？你能训练自己重新闻气味吗？是有一些希望的。事实证明，至少对于COVID，大多数人确实恢复了嗅觉。有时甚至在最初的其他症状出现后的
or their positive diagnosis. Some take up to two to three months, and during that period of time, their ability to smell might fluctuate. They'll smell something, and then it'll go away, and then one day they'll have a good sense of smell the next day, not. Unfortunately, it looks like about maybe 10% of people who have been diagnosed with COVID,
一两周内，或者在确诊后的两三周内。有些人需要两到三个月，在此期间，他们的嗅觉能力可能会波动。他们会闻到某种东西，然后它又消失了，然后有一天他们会有很好的嗅觉，第二天又没有了。不幸的是，看起来大约10%被诊断出患有COVID的人，
and who have lost their sense of smell, it persists for longer. Now, in other post-viral olfactory disorders, if you follow people out long enough, it looks like you can still recover even up to two to three years after you've lost it. You may not recover completely. You may not be back to where you started, but you might have enough of a functioning sense of smell to navigate your world and to enjoy food again. So we are trying to sort of jumpstart that process. And that's one thing that olfactory training is intended to be used for.
并且失去了嗅觉，这种情况持续的时间更长。现在，在其他病毒后嗅觉障碍中，如果你对人们进行足够长时间的跟踪，看起来即使在失去嗅觉两到三年后，你仍然可以恢复。你可能不会完全恢复。你可能回不到开始的状态，但你可能拥有足够的嗅觉功能来导航你的世界并再次享受食物。所以我们正试图启动这个过程。这就是嗅觉训练的目的。
That instead of avoiding smelling things because you can't smell, you actually stimulate your system with four or five different odorants that you smell religiously every day, a couple of times a day. Sometimes you think about what the odor smelled like when you could remember it. sometimes you look at a picture. There's different ways to do it. But the idea is the more you stimulate the olfactory system, the more you might actually regrow or regenerate the capacity that you had before. So does that mean that there are cells that are lost that can grow back?
与其因为闻不到气味而避免去闻东西，不如每天虔诚地用四五种不同的气味剂来刺激你的系统，每天几次。有时你会思考当你能记住它时，这种气味闻起来是什么样的。有时你会看一张图片。有不同的方法可以做到这一点。但想法是，你刺激嗅觉系统的次数越多，你实际上就越有可能重新生长或再生你以前拥有的能力。那么这是否意味着丢失的细胞可以重新生长？
Is that what's happening physically? It depends on the virus. Some viruses appear to actually affect the receptors themselves. It appears that in COVID, in a study that was done by Dr. Bob Data at Harvard, that what gets disrupted by the virus are the supporting cells, the ones that actually work to produce and feed the olfactory receptors. And so once that base gets disrupted, then you have olfactor receptors that turn over. olfactory receptors have a short lifespan. They regenerate continuously throughout life. But if the architecture isn't there to help them regenerate,
物理上是这样发生的吗？这取决于病毒。一些病毒似乎确实影响了受体本身。在哈佛大学鲍勃·达塔博士进行的一项研究中，COVID似乎破坏的是支持细胞，即那些实际致力于产生和喂养嗅觉受体的细胞。因此，一旦那个基础被破坏，你就会有更新的嗅觉受体。嗅觉受体寿命很短。它们在整个生命过程中持续再生。但如果缺乏帮助它们再生的结构，
then you're going to have a loss. And so that's the current main hypothesis of how COVID is disrupting the olfactory system. Once the virus is no longer affecting those supporting cells, they may regenerate, and then the olfactory receptors can start regrossi. their connections to be able to allow us to experience what is smell again. So you're working on an NIH-funded initiative to develop a rapid smell test to identify COVID cases. Can you talk about that? And why would a smell test be better than the test that we have right now? Well, we can't say that it's better than an actual diagnostic test, like a nasal swab or an antigen test or saliva test.
那么你就会有损失。这就是目前关于COVID如何破坏嗅觉系统的主要假设。一旦病毒不再影响那些支持细胞，它们可能会再生，然后嗅觉受体就可以开始重新生长它们的连接，从而使我们能够再次体验什么是嗅觉。你正在参与一项由NIH资助的计划，开发一种快速嗅觉测试来识别COVID病例。你能谈谈这个吗？为什么嗅觉测试会比我们现在拥有的测试更好？嗯，我们不能说它比实际的诊断测试（如鼻拭子、抗原测试或唾液测试）更好。
But it certainly seems to be better than the symptom screening that people are doing or the temperature screening that people are doing in order to return to the workplace or go into a building or a restaurant. I mean, every restaurant I go to in Philadelphia takes my temperature before I go in. And yet we know from thousands and hundreds of thousands of instances that this is a very unlikely way to pick up a positive COVID test case. And so given that there have been studies done by this international group of researchers, of which many people at Monell are apart, but worldwide, we know that the sense of smell, the loss of sense of smell, is actually more predictive than a fever, especially in the early stages of COVID infection, when you might not have a fever yet or you might not have any other symptoms,
但它肯定看起来比人们正在做的症状筛查或体温筛查要好，因为人们为了重返工作岗位或进入建筑物或餐厅而进行这些筛查。我的意思是，我在费城去的每一家餐厅在进入之前都会测量我的体温。然而，我们从成千上万的案例中知道，这是一种非常不可能发现COVID阳性病例的方法。因此，鉴于这个国际研究小组（其中许多莫内尔的人员是其中的一部分，但在全球范围内）已经进行了研究，我们知道嗅觉丧失实际上比发烧更具预测性，特别是在COVID感染的早期阶段，那时你可能还没有发烧，或者你可能没有任何其他症状，
but you might be infectious. You might be capable of transmitting the virus. to someone else. And so for that reason, we think it has more value as a screening test. Now, of course, it can be paired with fever temperature screening and symptom screening as well. But we think it will be, in the long run, as a suite of assessments, a better way to identify people who may have COVID, but who are otherwise asymptomatic. What might this look like? I mean, we know what these swabs are, and we've seen the guns that they point at your head to take your temperature,
但你可能具有传染性。你可能能够将病毒传播给其他人。因此，出于这个原因，我们认为它作为筛查测试更有价值。当然，它可以与发烧体温筛查和症状筛查结合使用。但我们认为，从长远来看，作为一套评估工具，它将是识别可能患有COVID但无症状的人的更好方法。这看起来会是什么样子？我的意思是，我们知道这些拭子是什么，我们也见过他们指向你头部测量体温的枪，
but how will they test your smell? Well, what we have is a card. It's a single card about five by seven, and there are three patches on it. Each one of them is sort of a glue, but only one of them has an odor embedded in the glue, and it's covered by a little plastic screen that you lift up, so you don't have to scratch it.
但他们将如何测试你的嗅觉？嗯，我们有一张卡片。这是一张大约五乘七英寸的单卡，上面有三个贴片。它们中的每一个都像是一种胶水，但其中只有一个贴片在胶水中嵌入了气味，并且被一个小塑料屏覆盖，你把它掀起来，所以你不必刮它。
Many smell tests are scratch and sniff. And while they're very good in a controlled environment, The intensity of the odor depends on how you scratch it. You have to have something to scratch it with. And so we were thinking practically about somebody going into an office where there might be 400 people entering, you know, at 8.30 in the morning. Something that could be done very quickly. So you lift the screen on each of these three patches. And first of all, you scan the QR code with a smartphone.
许多嗅觉测试是刮擦闻味。虽然它们在受控环境中非常好，但气味的强度取决于你如何刮擦它。你必须有东西来刮它。所以我们从实际角度考虑，有人进入一个办公室，早上8点半可能有400人进入。这可以很快完成。所以你掀开这三个贴片上的屏。首先，你用智能手机扫描二维码。
And that brings you to a little survey on your phone. You lift the patches, you smell each one, and you tell us which one has the strongest odor. Because the glue has a little bit of odor. We're trying to work on that. Then you tell us how strong it is. And that's another really important indicator of COVID, because you may not lose your sense of smell completely, but something that smelled, let's say, on a zero to a hundred scale yesterday as an all of a sudden smells like a 20 to you, something has changed, right?
这会带你到手机上的一个小调查。你掀开贴片，闻每一个，然后告诉我们哪一个气味最强。因为胶水有一点气味。我们正在努力解决这个问题。然后你告诉我们它有多强。这是COVID的另一个非常重要的指标，因为你可能不会完全失去嗅觉，但昨天在零到一百的量表上闻起来像一百的东西，突然对你来说闻起来像20，说明发生了变化，对吧？
And so then the final question is, what does it smell like? And your smartphone shows you four pictures with labels, and you have to decide which one it is. So basically, we're trying to test all three different functions of the way we use our sense of smell in one rapid test. And this can be done within two minutes for the first time you've used it, and probably less than a minute on subsequent times. So the throughput is pretty rapid.
所以最后一个问题是，它闻起来像什么？你的智能手机会向你展示四张带有标签的图片，你必须决定它是哪一个。所以基本上，我们正试图在一个快速测试中测试我们使用嗅觉方式的所有三种不同功能。这可以在你第一次使用时在两分钟内完成，在随后的时间里可能不到一分钟。所以吞吐量相当快。
And we're hopeful that the people that are using it will find it to be equally as convenient. There's been a lot written about dogs that can sniff out cancer and other diseases. And a couple of years ago, there was a spate of news stories about a woman in Scotland who could tell whether someone had Parkinson's disease by smelling their t-shirts.
我们希望使用它的人会发现它同样方便。关于狗可以嗅出癌症和其他疾病，已经有很多文章了。几年前，有一连串关于苏格兰一名妇女的新闻报道，她可以通过闻T恤来判断某人是否患有帕金森病。
How much does science know at this point about the smell of particular diseases and how might that knowledge help in diagnosis and treatment? We think it's very important. Back before there were diagnostic tests for a lot of diseases, it was very common for physicians to come and smell a patient. And actually, there are certain things like certain ear infections in a child give off a particular odor. They're, you know, of course, people who are in diabetic ketoacidosis have a very particular sort of fruity, apolly scent to them, which is an important way to distinguish them from
科学目前对特定疾病的气味了解多少？这些知识如何有助于诊断和治疗？我们认为这非常重要。在许多疾病有诊断测试之前，医生过来闻一下病人是非常普遍的。事实上，有些事情，比如儿童的某些耳部感染会散发出特定的气味。当然，患有糖尿病酮症酸中毒的人有一种非常特殊的果味、苹果味，这是将他们与
someone who's otherwise intoxicated or inebriated, right? Because they won't smell like that. Right, right. So moving on to that, scientists, like my late colleague at the Monell Center, Dr. George Preti, was using sense of smell and the volatiles that people emitted to diagnose other diseases. He was working with a group at the University of Pennsylvania at the Working Dog Center to diagnose early stage ovarian cancer, which, as you may know, is something that usually does not get diagnosed until late stages.
其他醉酒或中毒的人区分开来的重要方法，对吧？因为他们不会闻起来那样。对，对。所以继续谈谈这一点，科学家们，比如我在莫内尔中心的已故同事乔治·普雷蒂博士，一直在利用嗅觉和人们排放的挥发性物质来诊断其他疾病。他正在与宾夕法尼亚大学工作犬中心的一个小组合作，诊断早期卵巢癌，正如你可能知道的那样，这通常直到晚期才被诊断出来。
It turns out that inflammation from infection does produce an odor in our bodies that anyone, even naive individuals can discriminate. The question is, can you now get more specific? What is the nature of the infection? Is it viral? Is it bacterial? And one of my colleagues at the Monel Center, Bruce Kimball, just recently got a foundation grant to actually study that.
事实证明，感染引起的炎症确实会在我们体内产生一种气味，任何人，即使是未经训练的人也能分辨出来。问题是，你现在能更具体一点吗？感染的性质是什么？是病毒性的吗？是细菌性的吗？我在莫内尔中心的一位同事布鲁斯·金博尔最近刚获得了一笔基金会拨款，专门研究这个问题。
So there's a lot of work going on in the diagnostic area of using smell or at least using the chemical emissions from our bodies under different diseases disease states. Now, right now it's being done with dogs, but the hope is to use the dogs to be able to isolate what are the actual chemical signals and then build like an electronic nose or a sensor that can be used so that you don't have to bring a dog into an examining room and have, you know, during your physical exam and have him sniff different parts of your body. But
所以诊断领域正在进行大量工作，利用嗅觉或至少利用我们在不同疾病状态下身体排放的化学物质。现在，它是由狗来完成的，但希望是利用狗来分离出实际的化学信号，然后建立一个电子鼻或传感器，这样你就不必把狗带进检查室，在你的体检期间让它嗅你身体的不同部位。但是
honestly, if that's going to tell me something about my health, I'm all for it. That's okay, yeah. It's okay. It kind of works both ways. I had a vet a couple of years ago who wanted to decide whether my dog needed oral surgery and smelled her mouth. That was an important diagnostic tool for her. She was not trained in the U.S., but she was right, the dog needed oral surgery. Exactly, exactly. So, yes, that's a really, really developing area of research. And I think it holds a tremendous promise. And it's really one of the pillars of the Monell Center's strategic plan is to build on that. Let's talk about spell a little more generally. How well do scientists understand
老实说，如果这能告诉我关于我健康的信息，我完全支持。没关系，是的。没关系。它有点双向作用。几年前我有一位兽医想决定我的狗是否需要口腔手术，于是闻了她的嘴。这对她来说是一个重要的诊断工具。她不是在美国受训的，但她是正确的，那只狗确实需要口腔手术。完全正确，完全正确。所以，是的，这是一个非常、非常发展的研究领域。我认为它有着巨大的前景。这也是莫内尔中心战略计划的支柱之一，即在此基础上进行建设。让我们更笼统地谈谈嗅觉。科学家们对
how our olfactory system works compared with, say, our visual or auditory systems? What are the big questions that are unanswered? Well, we learned a lot going back around 15, 18 years ago, when the smell receptor, the ability to smell, the receptor was actually cloned and identified. I can say that the sense of smell is the last sensory system to give up its secrets to science. It was very elusive for very long period of time. And some of that was the difficulty in actually using scent to test. I mean, it's always been something of a niche science, which was partly what attracted me to it to begin with, is that there were so many unanswered questions that I found myself not,
我们的嗅觉系统是如何工作的了解程度如何，与我们的视觉或听觉系统相比？有哪些未解决的大问题？嗯，我们学到了很多，回溯到大约15、18年前，当时嗅觉受体，即嗅觉能力，受体实际上被克隆和识别了。我可以肯定地说，嗅觉是最后一个向科学交出秘密的感觉系统。它在很长一段时间内都非常难以捉摸。其中一部分原因是使用气味进行测试的难度。我的意思是，它一直是一种小众科学，这也是我最初被它吸引的部分原因，因为有太多未解决的问题，我发现自己几乎
almost knowing which way to turn, which was a good thing for a young scientist 28 years ago. But now what really is the major outstanding questions is how do all these receptors work together and tell our brain what we're smelling? We know that we can discriminate probably hundreds of thousands of different sense, and we do so with about 400 different types of receptors that combine in different ways to send a signal to our brain that tells us we're smelling this blend of coffee versus that blend of coffee. I mean, really fine-grained discriminations. We still don't understand the visual world and the auditory world work in two or three
不知道该转向哪里，这对28年前的一位年轻科学家来说是一件好事。但现在真正主要的悬而未决的问题是，所有这些受体是如何协同工作并告诉我们的大脑我们在闻什么的？我们知道我们可以分辨出可能成千上万种不同的气味，我们通过大约400种不同类型的受体来做到这一点，这些受体以不同的方式组合，向我们的大脑发送信号，告诉我们我们正在闻这种咖啡混合物还是那种咖啡混合物。我的意思是，非常细微的辨别。我们仍然不了解视觉世界和听觉世界是如何在两个或三个
dimensions. Smell might work in many more dimensions than that, and we're still trying to figure out. So for example, at this point in time, it's still unknown. If you take a chemical structure that is novel, how will it smell? In the same way that you could look at something on the hue or saturation, you know, the color wheel and predict what it will look like to someone who has normal color vision. So we're really at the beginning of that. And a lot of my colleagues are really working very hard on that.
维度上工作的。嗅觉可能在比这更多的维度上工作，我们仍在试图弄清楚。例如，在这一点上，它仍然是未知的。如果你采用一种新颖的化学结构，它闻起来会是什么样？就像你可以观察色调或饱和度，你知道，色轮，并预测对于视力正常的人来说它看起来会是什么样。所以我们真的处于那个阶段的开始。我的许多同事确实在为此努力工作。
But it is a very complex system. It's much more complex than vision or hearing. And so it's moving more slowly, but it is moving. I mean, the ultimate goal, of course, is to be able to digitize smell so that we can transmit a spell over our computers the same way we could. But we have to know how to create that spell. What are the components other than just putting a bunch of different molecules in a box next to your nose and trying to blend them?
但这是一个非常复杂的系统。它比视觉或听觉复杂得多。所以它移动得更慢，但它确实在移动。我的意思是，最终目标当然是能够数字化气味，这样我们就可以像我们能够做到的那样通过计算机传输气味。但我们必须知道如何创造那种气味。除了把一堆不同的分子放在你鼻子旁边的盒子里并试图混合它们之外，还有什么成分？
know, are there more sophisticated ways of actually digitizing smell the same way we can do with hearing, with noises and also visual stimuli? I recently saw a report about a 3D printer that was making meat, and I would imagine that smell would be really important that if the meat doesn't smell like meat and if you cook it and it doesn't smell right, then you're not going to eat, you know, printed meat. Exactly, yes. Yeah, I mean, it's the same.
你知道，是否有更复杂的方法来实际数字化气味，就像我们可以用听觉、噪音以及视觉刺激所做的那样？我最近看到一篇关于3D打印机制造肉类的报道，我想如果肉闻起来不像肉，如果你煮它，它闻起来不对，那么你就不会吃那种打印出来的肉。完全正确，是的。是的，我的意思是，这和
same thing that happens to someone who loses their sense of smell, right? All of a sudden, food becomes unappetizing, and that either leads them to stop eating because nothing works, nothing is pleasurable, and they lose weight, or the other side of the coin, which is where they continue eating because they're looking for that experience that they can't have. So it goes in both directions. So read that some people experience a loss of smell after they use a zinc nasal spray. And yet zinc seems to be really connected to the sense of taste. There's research showing that people with a taste disorder may see some improvement if they take zinc orally.
失去嗅觉的人发生的情况是一样的，对吧？突然之间，食物变得没有胃口，这要么导致他们停止进食，因为什么都不起作用，什么都不令人愉快，他们体重减轻；要么是硬币的另一面，他们继续进食，因为他们在寻找他们无法获得的体验。所以它向两个方向发展。所以读到有些人使用锌鼻喷雾剂后会经历嗅觉丧失。然而，锌似乎确实与味觉密切相关。有研究表明，患有味觉障碍的人如果口服锌，可能会看到一些改善。
So how can zinc be bad for smell, but good for taste, since the two are very intricately connected? Right. Well, they are separate sensory systems in the periphery. You know, the taste buds and the taste receptors and the oral cavity, of which they're all over our body. for the purpose of food, we'll talk about the oral cavity, are peripherally distinct, but they do combine in the brain because flavor is the quintessential combination of taste and smell, a little bit of texture as well.
那么锌怎么会对嗅觉有害，但对味觉有益，因为两者是如此错综复杂地联系在一起的呢？对。嗯，它们在外周是独立的感觉系统。你知道，味蕾和味觉受体以及口腔，它们遍布我们的身体。为了食物的目的，我们将谈论口腔，它们在外周是不同的，但它们确实在大脑中结合，因为风味是味觉和嗅觉的典型结合，还有一点质感。
Different chemicals are going to have different effects on different types of receptors, and zinc has been touted as a cure for smell loss, And it's also been implicated as something that causes people to at least transiently have a loss of smell. And so it's currently not recommended as a treatment for smell loss. In other words, inhaling zinc, a sulfate in the nasal spray. But it is something that people have used. It doesn't seem to be very effective and in some cases may actually cause the opposite effect.
不同的化学物质会对不同类型的受体产生不同的影响，锌被吹捧为嗅觉丧失的治疗方法，它也被暗示为导致人们至少暂时性地失去嗅觉的原因。因此，目前不建议将其作为嗅觉丧失的治疗方法。换句话说，吸入鼻喷雾剂中的硫酸锌。但这是人们使用过的方法。它似乎不是很有效，在某些情况下实际上可能导致相反的效果。
Of course, many people who were using it were also doing so because they thought it was going to ward off a virus or a cold. And the question remains, without a clear controlled study, would they have lost their sense of smell transiently anyway and attributed it to the zinc? So that's an open question. You've also done research in how smell is intertwined with memory. And a lot of people, I think, have a intuitive sense of this. We know that certain smells will bring back vivid images of a particular time or place. Why are smell and memory so connected? Well, we think partly because of their anatomical proximity in the brain,
当然，许多使用它的人这样做也是因为他们认为它能抵御病毒或感冒。问题仍然是，如果没有明确的对照研究，他们是否无论如何都会暂时失去嗅觉并将其归因于锌？所以这是一个悬而未决的问题。你还研究了嗅觉如何与记忆交织在一起。我认为很多人对此有一种直觉。我们知道某些气味会带回特定时间和地点的生动图像。为什么嗅觉和记忆如此紧密相连？嗯，我们认为部分原因是它们在大脑中的解剖学邻近性，
that smell is actually part of the limbic system, which is our emotional system, that allows us to experience pleasure, fear, sadness, etc. And also part of the hippocampus, which is where memories, especially emotional memories, are stored. When we smell something, we often don't identify what we're smelling immediately, but what we have is an association between that scent and a person, a place, an experience, a setting. So it's almost the cue that brings us back to that memory in a way that other stimuli may do so, but not at such an emotional level. A colleague of mine, studied this some years ago as well and showed that even though smells weren't better at recalling a memory,
嗅觉实际上是边缘系统的一部分，这是我们的情绪系统，它使我们能够体验快乐、恐惧、悲伤等。它也是海马体的一部分，这是记忆，特别是情感记忆存储的地方。当我们闻到某种东西时，我们通常不会立即识别出我们在闻什么，但我们拥有的是那种气味与人、地点、经历、环境之间的联系。所以它几乎是一种线索，以一种其他刺激可能做到但不在如此情感层面上做到的方式，把我们带回那个记忆。我的一位同事几年前也研究过这一点，并表明虽然气味在回忆记忆方面并不更好，
when people recall the memory that was associated with smell, they described it in much more emotional terms and probably felt much more emotional at the same time. And so we think that the interconnections in the cortex are what is responsible for that immediate sense of a flood of emotion or a flood of a memory when we smell something, you know, a perfume that our grandmother wore or the scent of a former boyfriend or, you know, the chalk smell of being in first grade in school when they still use chalkboards. Before COVID came along, one of the things that you were perhaps best known for was some research you did to determine the world's worst smell, an odor that virtually everyone would find repulsive. How did you do that?
但当人们回忆起与气味相关的记忆时，他们用更具情感的术语描述它，并且可能同时感到更强烈的情感。因此，我们认为皮层中的相互联系是导致当我们闻到某种东西时，那种立即涌现的情感或记忆的原因，你知道，祖母用的香水，或者前男友的气味，或者，你知道，当他们还在使用黑板时，在学校一年级时的粉笔味。在COVID出现之前，你可能最出名的事情之一是你所做的一些研究，以确定世界上最难闻的气味，一种几乎每个人都会觉得反感的气味。你是怎么做到的？
And of course, the kicker is what is the world's worst smell? Well, we had a lot of fun with that, Kim, actually. It was something that we were interested in from a scientific perspective because unlike taste, smell does not appear to be hardwired, our versions or preferences. Babies, you know, human babies, mice babies, all mammalian babies, will reject bitter tasting substances at birth, and they will avidly lick their lips to get something sweet.
当然，关键点是世界上最难闻的气味是什么？嗯，金，我们实际上从中得到了很多乐趣。这是我们从科学角度感兴趣的事情，因为与味觉不同，嗅觉似乎不是硬连线的，我们的厌恶或偏好。婴儿，你知道，人类婴儿，老鼠婴儿，所有哺乳动物婴儿，在出生时都会拒绝苦味物质，他们会贪婪地舔嘴唇以获得甜味的东西。
We don't have any real evidence that there are hardwired innate aversions or preferences for smell, and so we wondered if there were universal maloders, what would they be? So we looked at biological odors of biological origin, assuming that everyone would have had experience with that at some point in time. We know, for example, that there are certain kinds of odors associated with foods that are highly preferred in some cultures and repulsed in others. I mean, let's take durian fruit, for example, where the smell of it is, yes. The smell of it is just, you know, to most people in Western cultures, really unpleasant.
我们没有任何真正的证据表明存在对气味的硬连线先天厌恶或偏好，所以我们想知道是否存在普遍的恶臭，它们会是什么？所以我们观察了生物来源的生物气味，假设每个人在某个时间点都会有这种经历。例如，我们知道，在某些文化中高度偏好而在其他文化中被排斥的食物，与某些气味有关。我的意思是，以榴莲为例，它的气味是，是的。它的气味对西方文化中的大多数人来说，确实非常令人不快。
But if you grew up with that, and quite honestly, it really doesn't smell that same way once it's in your mouth. But you have to overcome that avoidance. So we looked at things like the smell of human waste, the smell of decomposing flesh, burning organic matter. I collected hair from my hairdresser and burned that and we captured the odors into a matrix. And so we tested a lot of people.
但如果你是在那种环境下长大的，而且老实说，一旦它进入你的嘴里，它的气味确实不一样。但你必须克服那种回避。所以我们观察了诸如人类排泄物的气味、腐烂肉体的气味、燃烧的有机物质。我从我的理发师那里收集了头发并烧掉它，我们将气味捕获到基质中。所以我们测试了很多人。
And what we were most interested in was people from different cultural backgrounds. And so I had some opportunity, I was actually working on summer programs in South Africa at the time. And so I took some of my odorants with me down to South Africa and tested people there, both white South Africans and black South Africans to see if there were differences, you know, culturally. We ended up finding a mixture of sense that comprised both organic decomposition, basically sulfur compounds and a little bit of human waste,
我们最感兴趣的是来自不同文化背景的人。所以我有机会，我当时实际上在南非从事暑期项目。所以我带了一些我的气味剂去南非，并在那里测试了人们，包括白人南非人和黑人南非人，看看是否存在差异，你知道，文化上的。我们最终发现了一种混合气味，它既包含有机分解，基本上是硫化合物，还有一点人类排泄物，
because that's a danger signal to most people. I mean, maybe not the smell of your own bathroom, but when you smell unfamiliar human waste, you really, in most cultures, and this was true, especially in places where there wasn't good sanitation, and I've worked in India on some of these kinds of odors as well as in South Africa,
因为这对大多数人来说是一个危险信号。我的意思是，也许不是你自己浴室的气味，但当你闻到不熟悉的人类排泄物时，在大多数文化中，你确实会，这尤其适用于卫生条件不好的地方，而且我在印度以及南非也研究过这类气味，
it can be a vector for disease. Now, the odor itself has no health impact, but it is a proxy. and it's a warning that there's something there that can be dangerous for you. And so when we mix those together, we came up with something that we called Stench Soup. And it really did revolt everyone who smelled it. Is it available commercially?
它可能是疾病的载体。现在，气味本身没有健康影响，但它是一个代理。这是一个警告，表明那里有对你可能有危险的东西。所以当我们把它们混合在一起时，我们想出了一种我们称之为“恶臭汤”的东西。它确实让每一个闻到它的人都感到反感。它在商业上可用吗？
I mean, if you wanted to use it on somebody you don't particularly like. I am not going here. If somebody wants to reach out to me, That's different, but yes, no, we are not commercially providing that to anyone at this point in time. But we were interested to at least see that, and, you know, I did not have the opportunity to test this on a two-year-old child or a toddler, who we know is sometimes not at all repulsed by the smell of their own diaper or even their brother's diaper, right? So at what point in development does this actually occur? And that's something that, you know, we're still very interested in. It looks like there is a developmental trajectory.
我的意思是，如果你想把它用在你不太喜欢的人身上。我不会去那里。如果有人想联系我，那是另一回事，但是的，不，我们目前没有在商业上向任何人提供它。但我们至少有兴趣看到这一点，而且，你知道，我没有机会在两岁儿童或幼儿身上测试这一点，我们知道他们有时根本不会被自己尿布甚至他们兄弟尿布的气味所排斥，对吧？那么在发展的哪个阶段这实际上会发生？这是我们仍然非常感兴趣的事情。看起来确实有一个发展轨迹。
The president and director of Monell many years ago, the former director, actually really looked at this. But it turned out to be that around age eight, children started to mimic their parents' preferences and aversion. So there's definitely a learning process that goes on. Well, Dr. Dalton, this has been absolutely amazing. I've really enjoyed talking with you. I appreciate your taking the time. It's a pleasure. Thank you so much.
莫内尔的前任总裁兼主任多年前确实研究过这一点。但事实证明，大约在八岁时，孩子们开始模仿父母的偏好和厌恶。所以肯定有一个学习过程在进行。好吧，道尔顿博士，这绝对太棒了。我真的很喜欢和你交谈。我很感激你抽出时间。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeatingof psychology.org or an Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org at speaking of psychology, all one word. heard at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何平台找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org（speakingofpsychology 为一个单词）。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的音频编辑是 Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。